what do you think about putin as a
leader as a human being on this world
stage within the context
of the cycles of empires that you think
about
well uh putin came to power
at the failure of russia's last order so
there was there was the end of communism
and there was the development of the
market economy the collapse of the
soviet union
and at that time
he
was appointed by yeltsin
who was an alcoholic and had problems
managing
and was put into power and the
conditions in the russian were the work
there was anarchy
um there was no money it was it had the
classic end of cycle ingredients it was
broke it was people were fighting with
each other was the anarchy and that's
when he uh came to power
and um there were not um institutions
the whole thing had collapsed and it was
not effective ministry of education
ministry of anything
and so the idea
was that they needed 25 years of
stability and they needed a democracy
and they needed uh the the improvement
of capital markets
um so he's been in that position
as a um as um
i guess i would call him um a
semi-autocratic leader in that
from all indications he would respect
the democracy
um and he's very popular he's won
democratic elections because he's been a
strong leader and he's brought
peace and stability to the soviet u to
to russia after the breakup of the
soviet union
and um
he's a strong leader
in pursuit of um the uh the country's
interests
in um a way where uh russia is not
um
um a significant economic power
um and but it is a significant military
power
um so um the issues and then there's a
strong alliance between russia and china
now
um so that's kind of the lay of the land
and then there are sensitivities uh the
ukraine issue
is uh a sensitivity um because of
um there are a lot of russians who live
in the ukraine
and there's also the issue of nato on it
on their border
um so there are those kinds of things
and he has military power and he has a
strong alliance with china
um and i guess that's my best summary of
what his position is
strong leader um popular
um
[Music]
these are not subjective interpretations
these are uh objective interpretations
you